for alleged po por aqui no is not on
cast pakis
that was terrible anybody want teach me
Spanish it's not that hard I'm almost
like halfway there I should be tell us
Mia's not hey what is going on YouTube
or as they say in Espanola hola
Oh what is going on dude [ __ ] my Spanish
is [ __ ] now I know this news is a little
bit old for you guys but I stockpiled so
this video is gonna come out anyways
even though it's all because I got to
talk about it can you [ __ ] believe
Jared the subway guy is a baby toucher
they found the child pornography which
later led them to finding out that he
was hiring young prostitutes to have sex
with them even though he's married
and he has two kids I might be making up
the chosen partner [ __ ] you look
like a horse and white guy so I'm
kissing you back to kids minimum do you
have any idea that nobody is going to
eat a Subway sandwich the same way ever
again
you know I'm [ __ ] up and some way by
the way has already been [ __ ] up
because they were found out that their
sandwich bread wasn't even made with
real grains of [ __ ] would been with like
horse glue or some [ __ ] like that and
now you have endorsed Christ you know
why I'm so upset though is because I
gave you the benefit of the doubt I
think I'm just kidding news I openly
said that you know what this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] he did not touch babies look at
him wholesome ass dude with the [ __ ]
button up khakis you know actually what
you do look like a rapist that's the
thing I don't understand why people are
so scared of ghetto people tell people
don't rape people will rob you will
steal from you will [ __ ] invade our
taxes we just might shoot you but we
ain't touching no babies but that's some
sick [ __ ] [ __ ] now understands the
women that he was with were underage but
they were prostitutes so I'm gonna go
out and fire say is that yeah those
little 18 or 17 year old girls knew what
they were doing
shame on you ladies prostituting
yourself out for some [ __ ] sandwiches
for some reason I don't think that
they're getting paid of money I think
they're getting paid the subway sandwich
or some [ __ ] that's my penis and I'll
give you Italian stuff literally and
figuratively huh for me I always try to
figure out how can you [ __ ] this up
before subway came into your life and
you had all these great sponsorships
your life was [ __ ] you were like 700,000
pounds when you would do a jumping jack
all of China was just like what the hell
you lost all that way
you got rich you got married you had
[ __ ] kids
you had the life but you done [ __ ] it
up because you wanted to touch a little
baby booty and the weird thing is I
think a lot of us forget that this is
like a psychological issue because if
you were a normal human being and yes I
use that word normal you wouldn't find
younger kids that don't have like
developed bodies attractive like as an
animal it doesn't make that sense but
either way do you [ __ ] them you do
realize that when you go to prison and
people see you there
they're just gonna make subway jokes
with you all the time you like [ __ ]
babies look at my foot law [ __ ] I heard
you like meatball subs you want my
meatball sub in your mouth [ __ ] five
five down a big slap you know what I
should have suspected this in the first
place because if you watch the news you
already know it's the ones that are at
least expected to always be the baby
bootie hold bootie Nappers you know when
I was a kid people trying to kidnap me
but they didn't really find too much
sport in it because it's too easy hey
little boy you want some candy ah
[ __ ] Jim is David again it's like
catching a fish this already did that
white man would always peep out a pest -
oh God and since I had this moment in
this platform right now let me go ahead
and talk about certain sponsorships
people out there who own these huge
companies you guys are sponsoring people
make sure that you sponsor people who
are crazy honest as so much of a
degenerate that he doesn't care what the
[ __ ] people think about it that's me
everybody knows who I am
McDonald's I saw you McDonald's you
tweeted Timothy DeLaGhetto
ad David Choi [ __ ] both those
two together don't even weigh as much as
me and I would do I guarantee you the
amount of McDonald's that there be in
their whole life I ate more McDonald's
in a matter of two [ __ ] days you
gonna treat me like a little chicken
Mick [ __ ] it huh ha there are no more
fish in the sea because of the amount of
filet-o-fish I've eaten chicken ain't
got breasts because of my chicken
nuggets these breasts were developed by
the Big Mac and you don't treat me like
[ __ ] like you don't even know who the
[ __ ] I am
you are the deadbeat dad that left their
child and when I come up I'm like hi
Daddy
like I don't know that [ __ ] you gonna
be a deadbeat daddy hi McDonald's oh
[ __ ] you I'm just kidding please sponsor
me